in northwest burundi along africa's
second largest lake it's as if time is
standing still
two years ago flood waters rose from
lake tanganyika destroying life around
it
and they still have not receded
since then thousands of people have been
living in this makeshift camp in gatumba
unable to return to the lakeside homes
and farms in burundi
life is miserable here the accommodation
the lack of food also worries me
sleeping in a place like this when we
have a nice big house
i can't say we have a good life when the
children sometimes go a day without
eating or eat only once a day
the children are also not getting an
education there are no schools
loss of income for their parents means
many have to work to support their
families
considering the effects that the
families are going through the indecent
housing living conditions
the children are also exposed that way
to rains to the cold
water levels in lake tanganyika are the
highest in decades because of excessive
rainfall
the amount of waste dumped into rivers
feeding the lake is also choking it
when i see all the solid waste
everything that is thrown into these
rivers afterwards these rivers are angry
they don't know what to do they have to
send it into the bloodstream of lake
tanganyika
burundi is one of the poorest countries
in the world it's also among the most
vulnerable to climate change
natural disasters account for about 83
percent of those who have been driven
out of their homes in burundi
there are pruded lives exposing the
reality of a changing environment
priyanka gupta al jazeera
a heatwave in india is breaking april
weather records temperatures have
reached more than 42 degrees celsius in
new delhi the weather department says
it's the first time in 72 years the city
has recorded such high temperatures in
the first half of april